you know how to lose all your money well
there's a lot of ways to lose all your
money
but you know how most of these athletes
and the music people or whatever that
you read about that Madoff 100 million
dollars they don't have any money
you know how they lost all their money
they did not manage their own money they
turned it over to someone else blindly
so well that's look guys I got me a guy
I meet these NFL all speaking the NFL
team and a kid comes up to me goes I got
me a man I'm like what do you mean you
got you a man what are you talking about
I got me a man I got a money man
translation the kid didn't have a clue
what he was doing he turned it over to
some guy who was slick and that's how
you lose it all now the Bible says in
the multitude of counsel there is safety
it is wise to take input from advisors
advisers are different than babysitters
it is your job to manage your money how
do you do that well if you don't know
squat about money then you need some
help but you don't turn it over to
someone blindly you are responsible for
that money so you learn from the adviser
an adviser gives advice they are not a
caretaker they give advice and you need
to learn from the advice and decide what
you are going to do the problem is in
sub segments of the financial services
world arrogance is taught as a chief
methodology for marketing and you sit
down with these people who have their
nose up in the air to the point that
their upper lip is sunburned and they're
God's gift to mutual funds or God's gift
to insurance and you're supposed to just
bow down and give them your
because they've got an attitude there's
a lot of that out there and sometimes
there's an enthusiastic ignoramus
someone that doesn't have an attitude
but has no brains but boy they're fired
up may not been that guy I've been an
enthusiastic ignoramus 100 miles an hour
in the wrong direction Wow
so what's all this mean it means when
you get ready to do something in the
financial world you are required to
understand it if the advisor that you're
working with the estate planning
attorney can't explain it to you you
don't go we'll just do whatever you
think's best and walk away this is your
life you are responsible for this no you
have to lean in you have to understand
if the insurance person says well this
is what everyone does that is not a
reason to do it
this is what I believe that's not a
reason to do it I'm sorry I don't care
what you believe all I want to know is
why be that little ten-year-old boy that
won't quit asking why why why why why
why you want me to roll this over why is
it a good idea to rather sell show me
teach me an advisor that does not have
the heart of a teacher in the financial
world is a Salesman get away from them
if your real estate agent is
strong-arming you instead of teaching
you as you're looking at houses then you
need a different real estate agent and
some of these people get busy they don't
mean to be bullies they don't mean to be
slick they don't mean to be salespeople
but they forget why they were originally
God in the business most of them got in
the business to help people and their
job is to teach you 85% of the people in
the financial world are taught how to
sell they're not even taught what to
sell they're just told what to sell and
they're taught how to sell their good
hearted but they're just dumb and
they're good salespeople but
they don't know much more about it than
you do when it comes to actually how the
investment works and so you've got to
get with a professional that has the
heart of a teacher now when you meet
with a professional that has the heart
of the teacher would you feel
intimidated you shouldn't unless it's
just on you
I mean sometimes just being around smart
people is intimidating I get that but
I'm saying if you're sitting there and
you're feeling overwhelmed you know
because all they're just thrown around
$92 words on the $4 concept no no no no
no that's nothing bucks know what we're
doing here their job is to teach you
when you sit down with a financial
advisor you should leave the room
knowing something that you didn't know
before you sat down and your spouse -
well I just feel good about him well
that's a good thing I want you to feel
good about him I want you to trust them
but don't trust them and turn it all
over it is not their job to make sure
you end up wealthy it is your job their
job is to show you how not do it for you
and then place the investment once you
both agree on what we're going to do and
so that's what we do here you get with a
financial adviser that has the heart of
a teacher and guys listen to me if you
and your wife meet with a financial
person and she comes away and she says I
have a bad feeling run-run
because that bad feeling is called the
Holy Spirit proverbs 31 says who can
find a virtuous wife for her worth is
far above rubies the heart of her
husband safely trusts her and he will
have no lack of gain if you have a
virtuous wife and she sits down and she
says this feels slimy that I have a bad
feeling this I don't know what it is I
don't know I can't really put my finger
on it but it just doesn't feel right
run
run when you have a sense that
something's wrong it's usually because
something's wrong
run Dave and Sharon Ramsey do not do
investing giving we don't do large
business transactions with people but
what Dave in turn rooms you sit down
with the players and Sharon very seldom
says a word until we're driving away so
what do you think it's actually not the
right question the right question is how
do you feel about that
because she really wasn't thinking that
much about it but she was feeling it get
with someone that has the heart of a
teacher you'll know they have the heart
of a teacher if you learn something when
you meet with them did you understand
something if I'm paying you 400 dollars
an hour to be my estate planning
attorney your job is to make me smarter
not being not impressed me with how
smart you are and if you don't do your
job you're gonna get fired your job is
not to do something for me not to tell
me what to do but to show me a couple of
really good ideas and why they are good
ideas teach me something show me
something I didn't know before and then
execute the trade for me caused it to
happen but I got me a man doesn't cut it
when you walk in and you blindly trust
someone and you dump the stuff on there
because they have a title and because
they were a little bit intimidating you
mess up so here's what we did when you
meet with one of our Smith smart
investor pros you click smart investor
Dave Ramsey comm you enter your
information they'll drop down a list of
the smart Buster pros in your area it
can be a little bit intimidating just
the whole idea around it right
especially if it's your very first time
meeting with a financial adviser that's
why we created the free financial
advisor question checklist for you to
take when you go you can get the free
guide at Dave Ramsey comm slash
questions to ask it's a free guide
Dave Ramsey comm / questions to ask the
free financial advisor question
checklist that will equip you to get the
interview done